joining me now someone who's been
following the border disaster from day
one
former hawaii congresswoman tulsi
gabbard tulsi i'm just really disgusted
with what the president said about those
border agents on horseback everybody
with a brain knows
that there was no whipping of migrants
going on
so what do you think's happening why is
he saying that it did and threatening to
punish
the agents
uh jesse the the issue here and i
consider joe biden a friend but he's
absolutely wrong and he needs to
apologize to the american people for
saying
what he said and here's why you know
he's somebody who's been very outspoken
as being against
autocrats autocracies dictators but what
he essentially did was act as
judge jury and executioner for these
customs and border patrol agents on
horseback how can they expect to have
any kind of fair outcome to an
investigation when the president of the
united states has already declared their
guilt and that they will
be punished and the bigger issue here
that this points to which is one that
that we all need to be concerned about
is
that if we are no longer a country of
laws if we are no longer a country where
we know we will presu we will be
presumed innocent
unless proven guilty then we don't have
a democracy and that's the increasing
feeling that a lot of us have is that we
are losing our democracy and moving
closer and closer to what essentially is
an autocracy this is the same type of
hoax that they use on police officers
sometimes where they take something out
of context or they just hear something
from one perspective and they convict
the person
and it creates a lot of animosity in
this country we saw this kind of hoax
again with russia
when the clinton campaign plants fake
news about trump and russia that lasted
years that was a hoax
this type of disinformation is so
dangerous to the country
i i feel like they got away with it so
many times that's part of their playbook
and they're going to keep doing it over
and over again
until when when are they ever gonna stop
the the saddest part about this jesse is
you're right they are getting away with
it and it's the powerful elite working
with the media working with the deep
state not acting in the best interest of
the country they're acting in their own
selfish interest to preserve their power
their position or money or whatever
their selfish drive is
they are unwilling to sacrifice their
interest for the interests of the
country and they have no business being
in positions of leadership at any level
in our society because who suffers as a
result of this it's the american people
it's our democracy and and they don't
care about the cost and the toll that
that takes and this is why leadership
that puts service above self that puts
the interest of the american people in
our country first is so critical and
essential especially now all right well
toasty that was very well said and you
said that joe is your friend the
president so maybe you could get on the
phone and tell them friend a friend
your opinion maybe he doesn't watch
water's world maybe he needs to hear it
from you tulsi gabbard all right that'd
be a good idea thank you
thank you jesse all right